1929.
Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel.
This is the site of the
first-ever Academy Awards,
or as it's more commonly
referred to, the Oscars.
Known for its glitz and glam, the Oscars
also represent the best of
the best in the film industry,
which makes it even more
tragic to watch it die.
The 2018 Oscars drew record-low ratings,
dropping nearly 20%
from the previous year,
and even if we disregard
the inevitable snubs
and drama surrounding the host every year,
it's evident that the
Oscars have a problem.
They're rigged.
So why are the Oscars such a big deal?
A recent study found that studios,
on average, spend an extra $10 million
just to run an Oscar campaign.
Now, it may sound like a lot, but it's
actually not a bad investment.
Over the past four years,
best picture winners generated
an additional $19 million
at the box office.
That's more than 42%
of total ticket sales.
"The King's Speech", for example,
was initially projected to gross
just $30 million, but after
its subsequent nomination
and victory, it went on to make
more than $400 million in the box office.
Today, the Oscars aren't
just an awards ceremony.
They're also a marketing event,
but it wasn't always like this.
"The Deer Hunter", a best picture
from 1978, was the first film ever
to use the Oscars as a marketing strategy.
Universal Studios
worried the film would be
a commercial failure due to
its grim and depressing tone
and came to a realization that the
only way to draw a crowd
was by winning the Oscar.
And it worked.
Another figure who took advantage
of the system was none
other than Harvey Weinstein.
The controversial film
producer was notorious
for his aggressive marketing
strategies to win best picture.
It's how "Shakespeare in
Love" took home the prize
in 1999 over Spielberg's
"Saving Private Ryan",
an obvious favorite at the time.
It's no surprise that Hollywood pours
so much attention and
money into the event,
but there is another secret.
The Oscars aren't that difficult to win.
That is, as long as you
understand the rules of the game,
and the key is all in the statistics.
For instance, you wanna make longer films,
ideally over two hours.
This graph charts the runtime of
all best picture winners since 1929.
There are no distinct patterns,
but in terms of probability,
longer films have a
better chance of winning.
Only three out of 90 winners had a runtime
below 100 minutes, while
28 ran below two hours.
And 76% of all winners
since 1960 have been
more than two hours long.
So why do the Oscars love longer films?
The answer is simple:
Because longer films tend
to feel more important,
and if there's one thing we can agree on,
the Oscars love important
movies, almost to a fault.
These are not important movies
in the context of cinematic achievements
but rather the buzz that surrounds a film.
It's the same reason why
film marketers work hard
to create that Oscar buzz, like the extent
to which actors went to prepare
for a role or the difficulties
behind the scenes.
There's no reason why
runtime should have an effect
on whether a film wins
the best picture or not,
yet, it clearly does.
This obsession with important
films is the same reason
why dramas are the king
of the award season.
A whopping 93% of best
picture winners are dramas,
while only 2% are action and fantasy.
This pattern extends beyond
the best picture category.
A study found that actors were nine times
more likely to receive a nomination
for their work in a drama.
Over its 90 years of
history, science fiction
and horror movies have
never won best picture.
It's why monumental works of cinema,
like Stanley Kubrick's
"2001: A Space Odyssey"
or Alfred Hitchcock's "Psycho" were
never even nominated, and this is
where we start to see the problem.
There is a formula to winning the Oscars,
and it's a formula that should
not exist in the first place, especially
in a ceremony dedicated
to rewarding good art.
The concept of picking the best film
to come out in any given year is ludicrous
considering how subjective movies are.
The Oscars are well aware of this,
and instead, they choose
a different approach,
rewarding the most
important over the best.
It's an admirable effort,
but it has its limits.
It ignores subjectivity entirely
and promotes a criteria
that makes a film important.
You might have heard
this criteria referred
to as Oscar bait.
An Oscar-bait film attempts to appeal
to this specific formula in order to win,
providing a safer
investment for the studios.
These films are often adapted
from a famous source material,
based on a true story;
even better, they include period dramas
with lavish costumes, and
historical biographies
of important figures, bonus points
for characters with a disability.
Since 1980, 89% of the
best picture winners fit
into at least one of
these five categories.
These films also meet a
similar criteria: mass appeal.
Oscar voters love critically and
commercially successful movies.
Of every best picture winner,
82% have a critic's rating
above 80, and 78% have an
audience rating above 80 as well.
This is a perfect representation
of how the Academy votes for best picture.
They use a preferential voting system
where the voters are
asked to rank the nominees
in order to reward collective preferences.
This means that the
least disliked films will
always win over smaller, niche movies
with ardent fan followings.
It also means that the Oscars will
almost always go with a safer bet
instead of films that try
for something different.
This causes another problem: fatigue.
Because the Oscars prefer certain movies
over others, their nominations
and winners look pretty
much the same every year,
whether it's a film
about journalists trying
to uncover the truth or a historical epic
about a man against a nation,
it's something we've all seen before.
And the same goes for talent.
Since 1970, about 71% of best
picture winners had a director
or a cast member who was
previously nominated for an Oscar,
a trend that carries until today.
Sure, it feels great to
watch DiCaprio win an Oscar
he well deserves, but
seeing the same people
over and over and over
again every year signifies
that other creative independent
voices are not being heard.
The Oscars are dominated
by enormous studios.
52% of best picture winners are
from the six major Hollywood film studios,
but that number rises to 81% if
you include many major
film studios like MGM.
The Oscars are dying, and they have no
one to blame but themselves.
What started out as a celebration
of great achievements
in filmmaking has turned
into nothing but a business strategy
for studios who compete for profit.
And the ones who suffer the most
from it are none other
than you, the viewers,
who no longer gain the insight
or the entertainment that was promised.
And all the drama, the issues,
and the snubs will continue
on until the Oscars realize what
their event is really all about:
movies.